hi there can you solve this well neither
can i but Wolfram Alpha can so this is
the thing that probably I have most to
think for for passing University
especially the math classes in it if you
don't know well from Alpha it is a
engine
it's from the creators of Mathematica
but it it is online and it can do
symbolic math so it can integrate this
expression for example and you'll get
the solution here and if you have the
pro version it can even give you a
step-by-step solution of how to get
there so this part of math is an
entirely different part then we usually
do with computers usually we do numeric
math working with actual values but here
it's about symbolic math it's about
manipulating expression in this case
integrating them so here is a paper by
Facebook AI research called deep
learning for symbolic mathematics by
giome lamp and Francois Giotto these
people have basically tackled the task
of doing these mathematical reasoning
solving these mathematical problems in a
symbolic way using neural networks so
they start out by saying here neural
networks have a reputation for being
better at solving statistical or
approximate problems I mean that's what
I meant by a numeric then at performing
calculations or working with symbolic
data and in this case they go about this
other than other people have
so let's look at how they did it we can
express symbolic mathematics in these
kind of trees right so an expression
like these up here would go would be
expressed into this tree so you would
have a plus this through 2 plus 3 sorry
of course there's an implicit bracket
here so you'd have this
was right here the two here and the
entire right hand side here so you can
basically decompose it into trees like
like this or this or this here you also
can have the differentiation operator as
a as a symbol in there just like any
other operator moreover you can
basically decompose everything into
everything they have here into binary
and unary nodes in a tree what that
means is either like the plus sign it
has two components so a left and the
right-hand side that should be added
together or like the cosine it has one
argument namely the thing that it should
take the cosine of right so a lot of
people have tried going about this
problem by working with these trees and
basically training neural networks too
so first they use kind of a parser to
decompose such a thing into a tree like
this and then use neural networks let's
say three recursive neural networks or
so on to to kind of make sense of the
tree and solve it in a recursive manner
or something like this but and that has
its limitations so what these people
from Facebook AI did is they viewed it
as a natural language expression problem
right so they say no no let's actually
go with trees as sequences right so if
you can see that this mathematical
expression for example is already a
sequence right it's simply a sequence of
tokens but there are many different ways
of expressing this so you can say two
plus three times the parenthesis you can
say three times parenthesis plus two you
can you know turn many things around and
there's always these parentheses make it
harder and so on so what they do is they
say okay let's actually go from this
thing to a tree so let's go up to this
tree representation and then let's take
the tree representation because
the tree representation can be
normalized and then let's put that again
into a sequence representation such as
this one and this is called reverse
polish notation and it has multiple
advantages over the old expression so
let's keep that on the right-hand side
here this is the same thing except it's
like what is called a prefix notation
whereas the thing on the right here is
called an infix notation infix because
the operators such as the plus is always
between its arguments right so it's left
and argument and it's a right-hand
argument in prefix notation the operator
is always in front of its arguments so
this operator here is the first argument
this end is the second argument this
right now the the cool thing is if you
express a tree like this you can simply
go and use a stack machine to solve it
so you can basically go I would say you
can go from the from the right here and
you see you it's like ah a 2 & 5 plus
and let's do it by hand
actually this is fun so we have plus 2
times 3 if you're a Boomer like me you
remember you had to use calculators like
this you couldn't use that in fix
notation so you go from the right right
you say 2 5 plus cool that's 7 so
scratch that put 7 here right so your
new stack is 3 2 times this right then
you go again from the right and you go 7
3 times
ok that's 21 cool 21 scratch this now
it's 21 2 plus 21 is 23 fairly sure
that's look correct me if I'm wrong but
this is how you would go about solving
like this so it is the same expression
as the original one
but it doesn't use any parentheses and
it is it is derived from the from the
tree basically so it is you can you can
normalize it much more in order to find
unique experts expressions so what this
system does is it true it transforms any
expression into a prefix notation such
as this one group stick and then it uses
a sequence to sequence model in order to
derive the solution now just how crazy
is this right so we come would go from
this thing here right from this thing
and the solution is 21 right and the
neural network is simply trained to do
sequence to sequence from this to that
it's sequence to sequence that means it
basically parses this as a token level
right and then it outputs these tokens
without so during training you simply
give it the you give it the input here
and you give it the output and it's
supposed to learn how to transform one
into the other without you giving it any
sort of mathematical ability right
without you telling it what is a plus
sign mean without you telling it is
algorithm that I just told you now um
this by itself is already pretty
astounding that you would try such a
thing it really transforms the string so
this is not the mathematical equation
but the string of this into the string
of that now they don't do it on numbers
like I don't think that would work as
well if you were to to make it kind of
calculate numerical things like this as
we said this is symbolic so what it can
do is it can for example integrate so if
you have an expression like
[Music]
let's see some on the bottom here so if
you had an expression such as a
polynomial rips here an expression like
this right you would like to find its
integral that is a problem that's one of
the problems we had at the beginning
right this integral right here
you can write this in a string like we
said and then derive its solution right
here and have the neural network learn
to map one to the other right to map
this to that so the way it goes is it
would map this into map this into its
three representation three
representation it would map this into
its prefix notation right it would also
map this to sorry let's take another
color here about this into its three
then it will map this into its prefix
notation and then that's the training
data the training data is take this
derive that right and at infants time of
course you won't have this here you'll
simply be asked to output a sequence as
a normal natural language like you can
think of machine translation right this
thing translates problems into solutions
it's crazy
I mean it's not it's not technically
super challenging but it's crazy that it
works or that it could work right so
we'll see how they this actually works
they use a transformer model which is
just which is a classic model if you
don't know what a transformer is I have
a video called attention is all you need
about transformers you can basically use
them to do these kinds of tasks to map
one string into another string
so yeah so they go into detail here of
how they construct the data set and how
big the problem space is and so on
ultimately they compare their system to
Mathematica I think and maple and MATLAB
which do the same thing so Mathematica
which is the kind of desktop version of
Wolfram Alpha that I've shown you you
have it here so integration is the task
of integrating let's say these these
symbolic expressions OTE order 1 and
order 2 or slightly different tasks
where you're asked to solve an ordinary
differential equation which is also a
task in symbolic mathematics if you
compared to Mathematica here and they
give it Mathematica a limit of 30
seconds
what Mathematica will do is it will kind
of search it the manipulations that it
knows right so the advantage of this is
it can always give you let's say a
step-by-step solution if it finds a
solution right it will just start and
we'll do a tree search manipulating the
expression you give in until it reaches
a satisfactory solution but then once it
has that it can give you a path through
the tree which leads to the solution
which will give you a step-by-step
solution so you can understand it the
system that Facebook designs here
doesn't do that it simply takes write it
simply takes the input tokens like this
is the input and it just gives you an
output that is learned so that the
network per se doesn't understand math
it simply learns from many many examples
that to transform to come up with good
hypotheses so if you compare here
Mathematica for example it can integrate
84% of the things that they put into it
it's not said whether it
it gets it wrong or it simply times out
in the rest I would say it times out
because probably Mathematica never gets
it wrong because it's a in actual
symbolic manipulator with defined rules
so I guess the rest of the rest 16% it
simply times out doesn't find a solution
where as the this Facebook system and
they say we find usually finds the
solution in less than a second finds
these solutions in ninety eight point
four percent of the time with a beam
size of one now what does the beam size
mean at decoding time if you have a seek
to seek model you can always opt to do
what's called beam search so when you
have a input sequence let's actually
give an example a cat jumps right and
you generate an output sequence let's
say the task is simply to continue the
sentence right to continue the sentence
so you can generate an output sequence
the output sequence could be over the
dog what you can do is you can this is
beam size would we call beam size one or
no beam search at all you can do it
what's called a beam search in that each
step we actually generate multiple
hypotheses and then keep the the best
ones in memory so you in the beam size
of ten you would always consider the ten
most probable solutions and you would
kind of evaluate all ten and then always
keep the ten best let's see how this
goes let's do a beam size of three in
our case so the cat jumps and then you
could come up with three different
things this sentence could continue cat
jumps over a cat jumps between and a cat
jumps swiftly right so these are your
three hypotheses then we go to the next
step
you have to evaluate each of those each
of them so like a champs over the over a
over me the cat jumps between the
between two and the cat jumps between
many the cat jumps swiftly end of
sentence comes swiftly over cat jumps
swiftly and right these are off validity
so of these nine you would now select
again that the three that overall have
the highest likelihood maybe that's the
following cat jumps over the cat jumps
over a and the cat jumps between two
these three right so you just keep these
three and then in the next step you
again from these three you would want
for each three hypotheses and so on so
this is what's called a beam search and
if you give it a beam size of 10 or 50
the system tends to improve even more
the way the system works is quite
different from Mathematica in that
Mathematica as I said is a symbolic
solver that never makes mistakes but
can't fail to give you a solution this
system simply generates an output
sequence this is not guaranteed to be
actually a solution to the problem it's
just a hypothesis but then you can
quickly check whether the hypothesis is
correct so the nature of these math
problems with integration you can simply
differentiate and with OTE you can
simply plug them in to see if they're a
solution it's kind of like your classic
let's say any hard problems or like a
Sat solving where you can quickly check
whether something is a solution so if
you have a system that generates you
fifty hypotheses you could quickly check
which one is actually correct
so these numbers here
mean that one of these 50 that the
system came up with was a correct
solution and if you allow for such many
hypotheses you can see it goes up quite
a bit for example the OTE solving is
almost the same and here it's even worse
if you take all the ease of order - it's
even worse than Mathematica but if you
allow for a larger beam sizes you see it
dramatically goes up and inside it's a
different approach I wouldn't be
surprised if Mathematica would actually
implement something like this very soon
or or just buy this off a Facebook or
something or a Facebook buy Mathematica
in whatever way this clearly is a
different approach and it appears to
work better but there's a caveat so
here's the caveat that I see with this
kind of thing these evaluations are done
on on data sets of course and this paper
goes into big detail on how to generate
these data sets right so they have to
you know pay attention to many things
like many solutions are equivalent for
example here you know that this solution
and this solution to this equation to
this differential equation are the same
so they you know have you have to use
the symbolic framework to check whether
the solutions are the same and so on
this it is very good work but they do
evaluate on expressions that fit into
their fit into their data set so here in
their data set they say okay we evaluate
you know expressions with up to 15
internal nodes leave values for these
for binary operators then these 15 unary
operators so the expressions that they
train on fall into this data set right
also just numbers from negative 5
five so it is it is kind of to be
expected that a system that is trained
on these things would may would perform
very well on these things as opposed to
opposed to Mathematica that is you know
a general purpose tool moreover if you
look at sorry I think this is further
done for example in integration for the
integration tasks they have three
different ways of solving of generating
data they have the forward way where
they simply use a symbolic integrator
to generate expressions they have the
backward way where they start from the
integral and then differentiate it in
order to obtain a training pair and they
have an integration by parts method so
these are three different methods to
come up with problems for this system to
be trained on and they have very
different properties to the effect that
if you train with one just one it won't
work well on the other so if you train
with the forward method it will work
very well on data that has been
generated with the forward with it so
this is down here this is what it's
trained on and this is what it's
evaluated on right you can see the the
diagonal is very very strong but if you
train with the backward method but you
evaluate on data generated with the
forward method it is actually very poor
that's because in one case generally the
solutions are longer than input in the
other case the solutions are shorter so
not only does this system only work on
the particular task here it is actually
very attune to the to the way that this
data was generated right so in fact I
would postulate that this training data
is only probably a very small subset
of all of the things that we would like
to integrate and again the problem the
problem is made kind of worse because
they if their evaluation set would also
come from their distribution so what
they've altum Utley shown is that they
can do this on a very skewed probably
very biased subset of this mathematical
problem and on that biased subset they
can outperform something like
Mathematica right they kind of defeat
themselves yeah if you look here they
even the different integration data
generating methods if you only train on
one of them it doesn't generalize if you
only train on forward data then if you
evaluate on backward generated data it
doesn't work so even the integrator can
can't really generalize so they have to
kind of combine different method and
even now we can probably easily find
examples that this integrator can't
solve so I mean there is a lot of cool
things here and they show a number of
properties that the model learns just
from without them telling it to and it's
cool that it works anyway as I said this
model has no program the notion of how
math works but also it kind of shows the
the problems if you if you do this via a
training data set in that if your
training data set is very skewed and
then your evaluation set follows the
same generation process they claims you
can make at the end are limited and to
be fair I don't know what claims they
made in the press generally so I think
there it's a pretty cool work check it
out and that was it thanks